well these are statistics that that no
one wanted to
talk about let alone report or analyze
and frankly
you know they don't do justice to the
scale of the the human suffering that
we're seeing across the country let
alone
talking about what's happening the
indirect consequences of this pandemic
the lockdown
and so on but we can perhaps get a sense
of perspective as to
where we are and it's worth just being
as clear-sighted as we can at the moment
this is a terrible moment for uk
mortality and for the economy as well
but let's just see where it stands
you know is the uk the worst in the
world a lot of people uh getting very
concerned about that
let me try and show you some of the
numbers and we'll start with just this
one obviously
everyone's been focused on this question
of whether we're gonna hit a hundred
thousand
uh deaths and actually on most of these
measures we are there
there are various different ways of
measuring this and actually each of
these measures
of death are subtly different as you'll
see in a second
so for instance you've got the office of
national statistics they collect numbers
on the basis of
when covert is mentioned on the death
certificate and by their measure
there are two actually here we've got
their weekly registrations which
isn't quite as up-to-date and you've got
the more update one which looks at daily
occurrences
they're talking about getting towards
about 108 000 deaths from covert 19 and
that's by
the middle of last week so we're already
well beyond that according to their more
comprehensive numbers what
why the difference i'll show you that in
a second and then you've got their
weekly one i mentioned a moment ago
and then you've got this the government
dashboard that's the one i think that
most people
focus on that's where if you've had a
pcr a positive
takeover tests uh 28 days before dying
then that's categorized
as a covert 19 death and then you've got
a different measure excess deaths we
talked
quite a lot about that didn't we and
what might be striking to you
is the excess deaths at the moment is
actually below where
that official covert 19 death toll is
now why is that
particularly given you'll probably
remember this from the spring back in
the spring excess deaths were a lot
higher
it's because back in the spring the
official death toll wasn't really
capturing
as many deaths as we're really going on
in the uk and we
know that a bit from that other measure
but what's happened
with this wave of the pandemic is that
there
are fewer deaths happening from other
diseases so
fewer people are dying of other things
uh more people are dying of covered 19
and when you kind of net it all off
actually you have fewer excess deaths
quite a lot fewer excess deaths in this
wave
than you had in the first wave there's
an important difference that's worth
noting nonetheless when you look at the
scale of what we're talking about
you know we have rarely ever seen
anything like this let's just take a
look at that
i was talking about the difference
between different measures so this is
the ons one and what we're talking about
here
these lines are just showing you daily
numbers of people who are sadly dying
and what you can see is there is a bit
of a difference isn't there between
these two
measures so the ons measure a little bit
higher uh back in the spring
than that official government measure it
wasn't capturing all of what was going
on
back then we weren't just we weren't
really testing as much but when you take
and you kind of look at the total
numbers that we're talking about so
below that line
and it feels awful and reductive uh to
put it in this way because we're talking
about a hundred thousand
deaths but nonetheless we have to try to
get a sense of the historical
perspective here and what we can do if
we do that
and tot up uh that total number is to
try to compare where we are now
with previous epidemics uh in this
country so we'll take that
and make that into kind of a bar we'll
put going to put on this bar graph
and draw a line so that line is just a
hundred thousand
uh deaths that's just over a hundred
thousand deaths what we're going to do
is we're going to bring in other
pandemics that we've had
in this country and epidemics over the
course of the last century
so you can see how they compare so we've
got the typical flu season in the 80s
and the 90s quite a lot of deaths around
26 000 or so
in the average flu season then that was
a bad flu season well this is a lot
worse it's kind of more than four times
worse than the typical flu season hong
kong flew up until now the worst
post-war
epidemic in the uk this is worse than
that worse than asian flu in the 1950s
and worse
uh not worse than the spanish influence
i should say the spanish influenza a lot
worse
about 200 000 deaths from spanish flu
and of course
you've probably noticed it already we're
talking these are absolute numbers
really what you want to do is to
population adjust them because we've got
a bigger population now and work out
what that number for instance the
standard spanish flu would be
if we had the same kind of population
today if it was the same proportion of
the population well
that would be a lot higher these black
bars here but what's striking is look
hong kong flu would be the equivalent of
about 97 000 deaths
today so this already and hong kong flu
was over two years it was quite a long
thing this is already considerably uh
worse than that
given that you've got no numbers
continuing to mount and that
bar there i'm afraid is going up covered
19 deaths are continuing
uh to rise and when we compare the uk
with other countries this this is
something that is quite important a lot
of people have been saying the uk is
doing
the worst in the world in this you know
terrible analogy
to make and i'm afraid you know the news
is bad it's not quite as bad as that
though when you take
the covert death tolls for different
countries and adjust by population size
well
here's what you get these are the
countries which are most affected
in terms of official and i'm going to
come to th there's a reason i emphasize
that
official covet 19 death tolls uh belgium
then slovenia eastern europe has had a
terrible second wave
uh the czech republic there and the uk
and third uh
place and then italy down a little bit
below it the uk bar going up but
i'd be very surprised if it got up to
the top so the uk is not the worst in
the world but it's certainly
among the top five on this metric and
it's worth just underlining you know
it needn't have been this way if we look
at the bottom five
uh in this league table by the way
that's 145 deaths
per hundred thousand it's a population
adjuster thing let's look at the bottom
uh five countries in this table and you
can see well you can barely even see
where their balls are there are bars
there but they're so
thin that you can hardly make them out
china for instance 0.3 deaths per 100
000
now a lot of people don't believe those
chinese numbers but look at the other
numbers thailand vietnam taiwan
and if you had other countries like new
zealand also very low
compared with where the uk is and many
of these european countries so it's been
awful
for much of europe and the uk one of the
worst but not
the worst and there is a different way
of measuring this as i say a lot of
people are skeptical about the numbers
why for instance isn't russia
up there why are none of the south
american countries which have very high
levels of covert at the moment and have
over the last year or so
why are they not there well it's because
their numbers aren't very reliable those
official numbers
that they produce but we can get a
measure of this by looking at excess
mortality just a number of deaths in
comparison to what the historical
average is and here's how things look
when you take the top 10
areas where you've had high excess
deaths over the past year
it's a very different picture isn't it
look peru way
above many of the other countries then
mexico then ecuador then
russia which officially has a very low
covert 19 death toll but has an
extraordinarily high
number of excess deaths suggesting that
maybe excess deaths are a lot higher
there
then belgium then spain then the uk the
uk just kind of climbing towards where
spain is
at the moment and then portugal and then
the us not all that far but certainly
uh below where the uk is right now
it's worth saying you know this this is
kind of a moving story right now
it's going to take a while before we
know for sure where the uk stands and
where other countries stand
what vaccines do and the good news is
that vaccines
are being distributed far faster than a
lot of people expected in the uk and
cases are starting to come down
so we may have seen the worst but
unfortunately that bar is going to
continue
going at least a little bit higher so we
will have to see
broadly speaking the uk among the worst
but certainly not the worst
in the world finally i just because we
we tend to look at the uk as a whole but
it's worth just
you know zooming into different areas of
the country to work out which parts of
the uk have been most affected because
some parts have really not had high
levels of fatalities from covered 19 i
should say again that's
that's the level of where the uk was 149
excess deaths per 100 000.
so let's just look at this heat map uh
of at the moment this is just england
wales
and scotland we don't have that detailed
data for northern ireland and
what you can see actually if you look
kind of closely the darker areas here
are areas where there was more excess
mortality so it's excess deaths
by region and you can see some hot spots
that stick out by the way
those those black areas that i should
say that those areas we didn't have
enough data for
but when you look at the dark blue areas
i'll zoom in so you can see it
there are bits that stick out so if we
zoom in to london
we can see newham has the highest of all
of these areas all of these parts
of the uk the highest proportion of
excess says 54
above the typical level uh in newham and
if you look around london you can see
it's many of those london boroughs which
are most affected
by covert 19 have the highest levels of
mortality
and that is obviously continuing to rise
at the moment and then look just a bit
further down
uh in that league table so you've got ob
and wigston so that's just south of
leicester
35 excess deaths remember lester having
a tough time in that second wave
of the disease but this isn't the only
part of the story there's been some
parts of the country like i say that
haven't been as badly affected the silly
odds has so few cases that it's
difficult for us
to actually put a number on it at all
but also places within the mainland for
instance
uh over here east devon two percent
excess death so
there was a massive spectrum of
experience it hasn't been awful
for all parts of the country but for
many parts it really
has been very bad indeed we'll continue
to bring you this data this analysis as
it comes through
it is depressing to go through these
numbers but it's also important to be
clear-eyed about it and to get a sense
of where we stand this is certainly a
pandemic that none of us have
experienced before
hopefully we'll never experience again
and that so far
is what the data is telling us